I have struggled with panic attacks. Assumidly from the line for ages, what I started treating
with the rife and supplements you suggested the panic mostly subsided except for late
afternoons and evenings. Can you think of anything that would cause this and do you have any
suggestions for what I could do to eliminate these AR tormenting? So typically, panic attacks
are from inflammation of the brain. So their inflammation can be from a pathogen. So it could be
from a living organism like lime or co-infections. That's possibility if they've been going on for ages
that I would say probably not a living organism. Any longer, I would say it would be damaged
that a living organism maybe initially did. You have the way your brain cleans things up
is through a type of glial cell called your micro glial cells. And your micro glial cells are
your scavenging cells think of them as macrophages in the brain. And they're their immune response
in the brain. They help get rid of toxins in the brain. They help get rid of pathogens in the brain.
They both encapsulate. They move. They are like little octopi that move around the brain to devour
bad guys. If they can damage, they can get damaged and get stuck in this phase that
causes inflammation. So damage to micro glial cells can be actually source of constant inflammation.
And that is the possibility. So micro glial damage happens because of trauma because of
toxin exposure to the brain because of bio toxin exposure to the brain in the brain. Things that
damage your blood brain barrier get across the blood brain barrier. That's why I'm totally against
vaccines because vaccines have nanoparticle elements that readily cross the blood brain barrier and
damage the brain. And you end up with what's called primed micro glial cells. I have a video on that
your micro glial primate neurological inflammation micro glial primate you could look that up as well.
And worse than that the next worst step is that then you after a period of time and that's going on
then you end up with antibodies to neural tissue so that you actually have circulating antibodies
in your bloodstream to neural tissues. So every time you stimulate your immune response you'll
thereby kill neural tissue. You'll kill that tissue so you can end up with demilinating diseases
and all sorts of different things. And then we give those different names like MS and all
like that stuff. But in truth it's simply antibodies not simply very dangerous antibodies to neural tissue.
That's what you see in these cases. Now what else can be can be stimulant of these things?
So you have to look for what are called triggers. Common trigger in any panic attacks, OCD issues,
anxiety issues, is glutamate increases. So a person can, so you have neurotransmitters in the brain.
Some are some are calming neurotransmitters like GABA in some are excitatory neurotransmitters
like glutamate. So glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter. You need glutamate and you need GABA.
It's all about balance. But if I have excess glutamate I'm going to have an increase in anxiety. So
what could cause an excess glutamate? Well you could actually be making too much glutamate
through converting glutamate which is an amino acid found in food to glutamate and thereby you're
creating too much glutamate or you're just not getting rid of glutamate very well because of
damage microglue or the brain. Certainly don't want to be consuming glutamate. So make sure you're not
eating a diet that has is processed foods that have any types of hidden glutamates. They can
amount of sodium glutamate. So make sure that you're protected that way. Decreasing inflammation
would be the other thing. You want to look at anything else that is increasing inflammation
and certainly food can do that. So okay all night long you're fasting right? You wake up in the morning
you've been fasting all night long fasting will decrease inflammation in the brain. So
therefore you're going to probably be better in the morning. And then as you have to eat breakfast
you have to eat to live and you have to eat lunch you're causing inflammation especially if you have
antibodies to different foods. So running a Cyrex array 10 would be very wise in this case
because as the digels on you're consuming foods you're causing more inflammation and then it's
building up and you're getting more inflammation in the brain. Your issues are worse in the afternoon
and evening. Maybe even causing sleep issues but by the time the morning rolls around you've been
fasting for 12 hours and now that inflammation is decreasing and you feel better in the morning.
So those are the kind of things that I would think about moving forward with this. You want to
chat about it more feel free to make an appointment we can chat more about it. But looking at Cyrex
panels, antibody panels especially Cyrex 10 food antibody panels would probably be a good thing.